shopify is one of the most incredible
technology platforms to be built in the
21st century
nearly 2 million businesses use shopify
to sell their products online
and that number is only growing the
company made nearly 3 billion
last year and is now the most valuable
corporation in all of canada
it's an incredible growth story and at
the heart of it all is the shopify
founder and ceo
toby lutky toby isn't like most big tech
ceos
even though he's worth billions of
dollars he's somehow very relatable when
mark zuckerberg live streamed himself
barbecuing in his backyard
pretty much everyone cringed and
instantly turned it into a meme but when
toby
live streamed himself playing starcraft
people loved it he actually got invited
to talk about starcraft on the pylon
show
and spent two and a half hours just
casually talking about the game he loves
so much
this was remarkably refreshing in a
world where so many ceos only do press
events when they're launching new
products
and they always avoid anything that
could be seen as off-topic whenever
someone goes and builds a massively
successful business like shopify
everyone wants to know the secret of how
they did it and toby has answered this
question directly before
because i was i'm a computer programmer
i actually succeeded in this but
looking back i was saying i only
succeeded in this because i was a
computer programmer but i don't think
that answer tells the full story there
are plenty of computer programmers who
try to build great companies only to
crash and burn
toby clearly has a different mental
model for building companies
than most entrepreneurs and i wanted to
know exactly how he thinks so i studied
the history of shopify
and boiled down his strategy to just a
few key points
in 1980 toby was born in a small town in
germany
like lots of other successful technology
entrepreneurs he began playing with
computers at a very young age
when he was just six years old his
parents gave him this computer
it looks ridiculously old by modern
standards but at the time
it was incredibly versatile not only
could toby play games on this thing
but he could use it to program and
that's exactly what he did by the time
he was 11 years old
toby was hacking games and building his
own levels we basically saw this exact
same story play out with tim sweeney in
my video about epic games
it's a really common path for
entrepreneurs and something i did myself
when i was growing up lots of tech
entrepreneurs fall in love with
computers while playing video games as
children
but most of them grow out of it and
start focusing entirely on business as
they get older
not toby though he actually claims that
video games taught him more about
managing a business
than anything else and his gaming
experience will become incredibly
important later in this story
by the time he turned 17 years old toby
was completely obsessed with programming
instead of preparing for college
he chose to drop out of high school and
become an apprentice at one of the
leading german tech companies
siemens this experience allowed him to
develop some really solid programming
skills
and start making decent money but he
wasn't very happy with the projects he
was working on
he was forced to build accounting
software for old-school companies using
java
and this just wasn't scratching his itch
to work on cutting-edge technologies
but then he had an idea he'd been doing
a lot of snowboarding in canada
and realized that there weren't really
any good online stores selling high
quality snowboarding gear at the time
this was 2004 after all and amazon was
still pretty small you could get
basic gear at places like sports
authority but finding the best gear
required
lots of hunting around so toby and a
snowboarding buddy of his name scott
lake decided to set up an online store
where they could sell their favorite
gear they called it snowdevil.ca
and the site is actually still online
today they have a really funny quote in
their about section that says snowdevil
is not your typical snowboard store
which sounds an
awful lot like many of the popular
stores on shopify today
building this site was not particularly
easy though toby had to cobble together
a bunch of different legacy web
technologies in order to get it all to
work
he did eventually get the store online
but it was clear that a turnkey solution
would have been a much better experience
but then something really important
happened one of toby's friends told him
about a new open source web project
called ruby on rails there was only a
small team of developers working on it
back in 2004 but toby saw the potential
and started collaborating with the core
team in order to test out what ruby on
rails could do
and contribute to the ecosystem toby
built an open source blogging platform
called typo this wound up getting over
ten thousand installs
and becoming really popular in the rails
community it's funny because
even though toby now runs a company
worth over a hundred billion dollars
he still has creator of the typo weblog
engine
listed on his linkedin profile with all
of this positive experience using ruby
on rails
toby decided to rebuild the snowdevil
e-commerce store from scratch
and this was a really crucial moment
shopify still uses ruby on rails today
and by picking ruby as the programming
language and rails as the web framework
they were able to really accelerate
their development for years to come
and this highlights one of toby's key
strengths as an entrepreneur he's a
deeply technical founder lots of
entrepreneurs learn enough about
programming to build a basic minimum
viable product and then start managing
software engineers
but toby became a true expert in ruby on
rails before launching shopify see
toby knew that even though ruby on rails
could speed up the development time for
new e-commerce sites
it wasn't fast enough most people who
wanted to sell things online
didn't want to write any code at all so
toby pivoted his snowboarding business
into what would become shopify toby and
his co-founder scott
took all the money they had made selling
snowboards along with some small
investments from family members
and started turning their snowboarding
website into a proper ecommerce platform
they spent nearly 18 months developing
the first version of shopify
and when they launched it toby used an
online name generator to come up with
the brand name the company was
originally called
jaded pixel which i think we can all
agree is a lot less catchy than shopify
but that name didn't last very long
scott had more experience than toby
running businesses and knew that they
needed something catchy
so he decided to combine the words
simplify and shopping
to create shopify amazingly the domain
name was available
so they switched over immediately their
2006 launch went fairly smoothly
although toby and his team didn't really
know exactly how big shopify could get
they delivered a great product that
allowed merchants to set up a website
quickly
customize a theme track their orders and
manage their inventory all without
writing a single line of code
the only problem was the business model
instead of charging shopify merchants a
flat fee like they do now
toby wanted to take a percentage of
revenue from every store
this model works great for small
businesses but as these companies start
to grow
the shopify fees can really add up
customers had to pay three percent of
their sales to shopify and the cost of
using the platform could skyrocket if
the business got big
now there weren't really all that many
big companies using the platform at that
time
but every entrepreneur is optimistic
about their business and the idea of
paying shopify millions of dollars in
fees once their business got huge
made them hesitant to sign up in the
first place so toby changed the model
entirely
shopify switched to flat rate pricing in
2007
and merchants started using the platform
in droves the growth allowed them to
raise 250
000 from an angel investor named john
phillips this was a really critical
moment for the company
because up until this point toby had
actually been the chief technology
officer
and scott lake had been the ceo but
after the funding came through
scott left the company to work on a new
venture and toby had to take over as ceo
this was a big shift for toby who had
never really been in a management
position before
and was primarily focused on just
building great software but john
phillips stepped in as a mentor to toby
and the results have been really
spectacular toby has leveraged his deep
understanding of software engineering
into a successful leadership model
developers want to work with people who
understand the craft of software
development
and toby is the perfect engineering
manager in this regard
even though toby was still in his 20s he
became a great leader because of his
ability to look at problems from an
engineering perspective
in his first year as ceo toby did a
great job he grew the team to 10 people
got the company to over a million
dollars in revenue and was able to
become
cash flow positive they also landed
tesla as a customer which is pretty
crazy to think about considering how
small both of those companies were back
then
and where they are now even with all
this success
toby was still unsure about where
shopify would go he enjoyed running the
snowboarding store as a lifestyle
business
and if they were growing profitably
maybe they didn't need to go the
traditional venture capital route
but then something incredible happened
raising venture capital only makes sense
when you have a huge addressable market
and are absolutely sure that more money
can actually accelerate your growth
so in a typical engineering fashion toby
ran an experiment to evaluate the impact
that additional capital would have on
shopify's growth trajectory he split
a small marketing budget across a few
different tests
and they all outperformed expectations
one test was to incentivize web design
agencies with a referral program
shopify would give web designers a share
of future profits
if they used shopify as their e-commerce
platform of choice
toby also partnered with tim ferriss to
run a business competition
to promote the platform essentially
whoever built the biggest business in a
given amount of time
would get a hundred thousand dollar
bonus directly from shopify
toby really couldn't spare the extra
cash at the time since they hadn't
raised proper venture capital yet
but he took the risk anyway and it paid
off massively the companies that joined
the competition
wound up generating over three million
dollars in revenue and brought a bunch
of positive attention to the company
these successful growth tests really
changed toby's perspective on the
business
it was clear that there was room in the
market for an e-commerce platform like
shopify
as big as amazon was in 2010 companies
still wanted to be able to own their
customer relationship
and shopify made this dead simple to do
so toby raised a 7 million dollar series
a
led by bessemer venture partners this
cash injection allowed toby to really
expand the vision for what shopify could
become
they developed an api that let
third-party developers build apps and
integrations to solve
any problem a customer might have this
app store became incredibly important in
making shopify a real platform
and toby actually mentioned that he got
this idea from bill gates when he was
just 16
toby read a book about bill gates and
learned a pretty significant insight
see back in 2010 every company wanted to
be a platform company
all the hot social networks like
facebook and twitter were platforms with
network effects
and had grown to enormous scale with a
company like shopify
there isn't really a network effect but
that's where bill gates's insight about
platforms comes in
bill said that you're only really a
platform if the value of the ecosystem
on top of the platform
is larger than the company that owns the
platform that's certainly true for
microsoft windows
and it would quickly become true for
shopify and this is toby's second key
strength as an entrepreneur
he's constantly evolving his product
offering when shopify first launched
the value propositions listed on their
landing page were hosting
bandwidth and security today that's all
table stakes
so shopify now focuses on featuring
beautiful templates
smooth payment processing and a
world-class plug-in
ecosystem the idea that shopify could be
an ever-evolving platform
and eventually cater to every type of
online store
really changed the company's trajectory
when toby raised his series at the end
of 2010
the company had about 20 employees one
year later
shopify had over a hundred employees
sales growth took off as well
in just 12 months they went from
generating 275 million dollars across
10 000 merchants to more than 750
million dollars
across 40 000 merchants now shopify only
keeps a small percentage of that
but it was still enough for them to pull
in 24 million dollars in net revenue but
the growth didn't stop
there next year they were able to double
their net revenue to 50 million dollars
that's exactly what you want to see if
you're running a venture backed software
as a service company you can't stop at
50 million dollars though when you're
venture backed
you're aiming for an ipo and toby knew
that the market for shopify was huge
so he kept expanding in 2013 shopify
launched point of sale
which would allow merchants to run their
physical retail stores using the same
software that powered their website
more and more direct direct-to-consumer
e-commerce companies were opening
physical storefronts
so having a product that could handle
both online and offline sales
was a huge benefit then a year later
toby and his team
launched shopify plus i was actually one
of the first shopify merchants to join
plus
and it was a game changer for me at the
time my company soylent was growing
really fast we were scheduled to appear
on the colbert report to discuss the
product
and we knew we needed our ecommerce site
to perform under immense traffic
appearing on national tv in front of an
audience of millions drove an insane
amount of customers to our site and
keeping our own servers online
would have been incredibly difficult but
because we were on shopify
everything went smoothly and i was able
to enjoy the show
and the after party without worrying
about the site going down
shopify plus allowed bigger merchants to
use the platform with confidence
plus had uptime guarantees and a bunch
of professional level features that were
essential for larger organizations
shopify could still service mom and pop
shops but now big companies like
unilever and google could use shopify as
well
this propelled shopify to an ipo in 2015
which valued them at 1.3 billion dollars
that was great for a relatively young
company but the stock has grown by more
than a hundred
x since the ipo incredible performance
there are a few obvious reasons for this
growth shopify was using the best
technology
they rode the massive wave of e-commerce
growth and they didn't have all that
many significant competitors
but i think the true reason for
shopify's success comes back to toby
litki i've met a lot of successful
entrepreneurs
but toby stands out to me as the most
adaptable of them all
and there are a few great stories to
illustrate this trait
as he was scaling shopify toby needed to
upgrade his office space in ottawa
to accommodate the next wave of hires
the lease was running out on his current
building
and the next place wasn't move-in ready
yet so they were in a jam
as a plan b toby prepared the team to
work from home
in case they got stuck without a place
to work for a while
the new bigger office wound up being
ready on time
so they could have just moved in without
any disruption but toby had another idea
he wanted to see if working from home
could be viable
so he told everyone to spend a month
working remotely even though they had a
fully functioning office available this
was all before kovit
and the experience made the company more
flexible and they learned a lot about
how they
collaborate this flexibility also played
a big role during the shopify developer
conference in 2017. they were hosting
the event in san francisco
and there was an unexpected power outage
the entire building was closed off to
visitors
but instead of canceling all the
sessions for the day they just held the
conference outside in the parking lot
most people would be phased by
unexpected events like this
but toby is at his best in these
situations and that's toby's third key
advantage as an entrepreneur he thrives
on
change this all comes back to his
experience as a starcraft player
winning a competitive rts game like
starcraft requires managing lots of
different resources with imperfect
information
and i'm not just talking about in-game
resources like minerals
the most important resource is actually
your attention
the game is incredibly fast-paced and
where you spend your limited attention
will determine whether or not you win
toby is a master of allocating his
attention to the most
valuable opportunity at shopify and
that's why the company is so successful
today
so i encourage you to think like toby as
you're building your startup and maybe
go play some starcraft when you need to
clear your head
i'm more of a counter-strike guy myself
but to each their own
if you want to chat with me you can
always just dm me on twitter
and please check out this recommended
video the youtube algorithm thinks that
you'll really like it